[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER 1:
One, two, three.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
It says yogurt.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Now
do we need butter?
FEMALE SPEAKER 4: Uh, no.
The other way.
Like that.
This one, we fold it like this.
Wow!
Aren't we clever.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: I
want to cut your hair.
Where is the black one?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Oh,
it's in my eyes.
Is that what my hair looks like?
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Green!
MALE SPEAKER 3:
Yeah, that's right.
FEMALE SPEAKER 4: I did it.
You do that one.
MALE SPEAKER 3: All right then.
MALE SPEAKER 1: That's it.
Wait until they've got all
white and nice and clean.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
"He said to us,
'Why do you sit
there like that'"?
[MUSIC PLAYING]